peach tink tink welcome back to the big
Sam Jeff I guess now featuring even more
peach peach she has a stomachache today
so she's gonna sit in here with that PG
get special treatment special treat me
oh poor baby she don't feel good all
right welcome back you guys good to see
your faces under sue sue examples that
is sponsored by tracker guys these
little things are unbelievable it's
called tracker like track and then are
basically the little eye a little tiny
coin size devices that you can put in
your bags you can put in your car you
put on things that you lose off and your
keychain your phone and you download the
app and you can find your stuff from
anywhere always it's it locates yourself
in seconds it's so amazing I literally
just ran around the house and started
putting them on everything it's on your
drone it's a backpack full of your
camera supplies yeah so I'll get to more
of that later right now guys go to the
tracker comm that's th e tracker calm
and use promo code Jam Julian for the
30% off your entire order sepsis also
brought to you by bark box guys some of
the kids dog toys we showed you guys
most of the doctors last week in peach
hasn't put hers down that's more toy she
has not separated yeah bark box is a
monthly subscription service for dog
toys and treats that you can get
delivered to your house and right now
you can get one month free one month
free when you sign up for a 6 or 12
month membership so thank you bark box
guys right now go to bark box calm slash
Jenna Julianne to get that deal thank
you responsive you're still withholding
that toilet paper old toy from her
Julian has this theory that he's gonna
wait till she destroys a toy to give her
a new toy yeah because otherwise she
just slowly destroys everything let have
choices Petey you want all the toys all
the choices she's so sweet she has so
many choices right now look at her
holding my hand and I love when she does
that
she really needs attention today yeah
she needs extra love ah sorry about my
shirt peach he's wearing a curvature
experiment cermets shirt I really want
to make a part two to how to care for
your sermons video yeah you were talking
about that what would what would it look
like it's it's in the works in my brain
all right I gotta think and work it out
in my mind
Thank You Jaime good listen if if you
guys would want to see that I don't know
people want to see it they do yeah they
do it's just so goofy look at like
making that stuff you know I know but
it's good it's like fun it's fresh Dupin
it's fresh content yeah ha ha I hate you
so what are we talking about today I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
Wow the marina joy situation that was
going on on the Internet yeah that was
interesting it's just it's wild man like
the whole thing was wild
it seems to be resolved at this point
but she has now what over a million
subscribers she is almost 2 million it
was Jim man yeah she went from like 600
to like 1.7 or the quick yeah I mean for
those of you that aren't familiar
basically she's a fashion blogger and
people wearing kara yeah people were
concerned that her videos she had some
visible bruising she started acting
really bizarre Lee and people were
coming up with these wild theories that
she was like kidnapped or being held
hostage or uh being abused by a domestic
partner or getting addicted to drugs or
something like that yeah cuz she started
just acting kind of strange and the
bruises are a lot bruises are a lot um
but the internet took it upon themselves
to start a hashtag save marina Joyce and
it got out of control man it was one of
those things that the internet just kind
of ran with and like there was no
stopping it you know what I mean like a
couple people and turned into a couple
hundred people so I'm trying to put her
in bed and before you knew it it was
like he was trending on Twitter and
everyone everyone smile was talking
about it and then you look at these
videos and there's these leaked videos
are they fake
real and honestly for me I think the
weirdest part was that when Phil Eadie
interviewed her that I was just going to
say that was one of the weirdest
interviews I've ever watched you're
expecting because he's you know he
looked at Franco by the way yeah he had
her on his show and um you know he's
well-spoken he's when he talks to
someone you're expecting a very clear
concise conversation where you can
because you know he expresses what he
wants to ask a person very well so
you're like if he's interviewing someone
it's got to be made clear yeah and it
wasn't forward question it wasn't he was
very straightforward he was very like
concerned sincere but also like kind of
just asking straight-up questions and
she was down because she obviously agree
to the interview and when it was over it
it really just felt like well no I
didn't get any closer I didn't get any
sort of light shed on what my questions
were you just kind of answered them very
weirdly you repeated yourself over and
over and it made me feel like I was in
the twilight zone
yeah the repeating herself over and over
is bizarre like she does that even on
Twitter she'll type a sentence that's
just an on sentence but I see I don't
I'm like everyone I don't I didn't know
who she was before this so was she
always like that was she always kind of
offbeat and like well you can watch her
old videos she wasn't so that's what's
so weird and like sitting you know where
we are it's like okay something's
happening Mike Simon's not you know
there's something that's not being
talked about what the interview was
crazy because the main takeaway was that
she honestly feels like people cared so
much about her so all of the the new
people that have subscribed to her
channel and that are following her now
are the people that really care about
her yeah and I think what a rose-colored
glasses way to look at that because it's
literally millions of people subscribed
to her because the waiters got a train
crash no no no I think most people
genuinely are concerned for her but it's
not like you're following her because
you want to buy those dresses she's
modeling yeah I mean people want to see
what's gonna happen you know yeah and
when she answered that question they're
being honest with themselves so ask her
he was like do you have any sort of
feeling
maybe all these new subscribers are here
for the wrong reasons and she was like
oh no I love them all they're all here
because they care about like that's
that's delusion talk like you have to at
least understand the situation like
you're you're acting right now like you
went from 600 to 2 million subscribers
in a week because people just suddenly
like found you and you're like amazing
no like you kind of are in the middle
this very weird situation that the
internet has kind of lost their mind
about and you're denying that Betty it's
even a thing right well I mean yes and
I'm I I thought this would be an
interesting topic just to talk about
maybe you guys in the comments sue
because the internet or at least the
YouTube community has never had a
situation on this scale where the
audience took it upon themselves to sort
of police someone's life choices do you
mean yeah maybe they're not life choices
maybe she's dealing with a mental
illness which is always a possibility
but they took it upon themselves to
create the hashtag to like really like
the Internet planned an intervention
right no world a level of concern for
her yeah um I don't know
not in my memory or that I'm aware of
has that happened within the YouTube
community before yeah I mean but like
some of it was just opportunistic trolls
being like yeah all the edits the
pictures of her the fake information the
edited tweets the edited all that stuff
like people were just taking every
chance to make that fake Twitter video
being like don't come here it's a setup
because she tweeted out the location
zone early morning 6:00 a.m. rave that's
happening early in August like I don't
know there's just a lot of wild
conspiracy theories and I guess my
hypothetical question is do you think
it's right for an audience of a person
going through some serious personal
issues to have like I guess the right or
is it right what the audience did I
think the answer to that question just
straight up is probably no but at the
same time it that's irrelevant you know
when you when you're on the Internet
right like the way your audience acts
the way everyone acts on the Internet
the right and wrong kind of changes when
you become a youtuber so when you have
these hundreds of thousands of people
following you and they do something like
this maybe it's not morally right maybe
it's like you wouldn't want to go do
that and then can't come home tell your
mom that you did that that day but it's
not how the internet works like it's
just kind of like a mob that creates a
reality and then goes with it and she
has to understand that like being out
there that can happen all of us
understand that like this kind of stuff
happens you get you get you know raked
over the coals sometimes for things that
you shouldn't but you know that that's
kind of the nature of the internet so
it's not right or wrong it's just kind
of I mean I think it's wrong
but I don't think that matters yeah well
it's just interesting to watch because
the platform is democratized so people
really feel like if this person's going
through something it's our job to help
them yeah you know all right
I'm convinced that Law and Order SVU has
already written up an episode because
there was some theories that she was
going through some sort of domestic
abuse because they had linked to a
picture of her having one fingernail
painted which was apparently a thing for
domestic violence and the bruising
people were thinking that maybe she was
being abused
um I'm convinced that law and order SVU
Zara episode that's like a youtuber
that's trying to cry out for help by you
making a blog about it
yeah we're constantly posting guns
hinting it that they need help you know
that's the case though like if you know
let's not rule out anything because no
one knows except for marina what's going
on but like if that was the case her
audience is doing a great thing and I
think the meds would rather err on the
side of you know being a little extreme
as an audience and caring about her then
have something happened to her and not
have said anything will we the hyperbole
yeah I mean the way the hashtag started
out came from a good place the people
who were concerned initially were her
fans who were legitimately like okay
something's happening let's let's speak
up let's let's tell everyone that came
from a good place that was like her
audience trying to rescue her
um I don't I don't have any idea what's
going on with her but the way that she
made that vapor she was like in her
video she was like let's have a meet-up
I'd love to meet you guys let's meet
like the sentence was unbelievable you
listen to what she's saying and it's so
repetitive and like Twilight Zone II
that you're like what am I even watching
and so something is going on I'm
convinced something is going on drugs
abusive boyfriend something danger
whatever there is there is absolutely
yeah mental illness there was something
happening and it's confusing every every
day that passes because then she goes on
the interview and then she's still kind
of like she like basically repeated what
she did on her video on the interview
she cried out for help in a way like it
made you feel like her answers to those
questions were like are you telling us
like the opposite of what you're saying
right now are you giving us code like
but then I don't know it's just very
weird it is weird but you like that
you'd like you said the internet lives
for this stuff in good ways and bad ways
yeah love these people with their hearts
in the right places and then there's
people yes or just they don't really
care what happens to her they just want
to see it for sure
you know for sure yeah it's uh one of
the things I'm curious to see how it
pans out obviously I hope everything
gets figured out with her I hope she's
okay and I mean well okay if you were a
youtuber you are more you listening if
you were a youtuber with a large
following and something was going on in
your mind in your life and some part of
you and people could tell that you were
seriously going through something
whether or not you were even aware of
what it was for example if she has some
sort of mental illness that's going
untreated and your audience was really
concerned about you and she's not
necessarily cognizant of it because she
has maybe she's a scenario yeah or you
know maybe she's using a lot of drugs
and you know people I'm sure everyone
out there has an experience with someone
that they know or have seen that go
through drug addiction many of those
people do not they have the
understanding that they can control it
you know they are in denial about the
fact that it's really affecting their
lives so like with those two examples we
were going through mental illness and
you're not you don't think that you've
changed do you think that you're still
the
or you're into drugs and you think you
have control over it but it's severely
affecting your life but your audience
can see either one would you want your
audience to step in and have that vocal
ability to try and get you help
well in this scenario I'm going to say
yeah just because if I'm being affected
so deeply by something in my life that
I'm letting it bleed into my videos that
I know a lot of people watch then I'm
kind of signing up for people to come to
me and be like what's going on on the
internet because you know in a situation
where I desperately would not want my
audience to be concerned about something
in my life I would be so careful not to
let any of that show in my videos but
then again the situation where you're
unaware mental onus things that you
can't necessarily control you know it's
it's it's a double-edged sword it's a
good thing and a bad thing it's like yes
I have all these people concerned yes I
have hashtags going yes people are aware
of me but then also there's this giant
new population who are just here for the
free show they want to want to be
entertained at your expense and that
that's what makes the answer to this
question so difficult yeah it's a gray
area I mean here's where I'm coming from
I feel like in a way just even
mathematically if I post it on my
channel every week you know we do the
podcast with my radio show if at some
point like there are a lot of people
that maybe see me on the internet more
than I see my family for example like if
you weren't here and I just lived alone
and my only connection to other people
regularly was the internet which I do
more often than see other human beings
sometimes those are the people that I
guess I'm sort of relying on to juda I'm
saying yeah yeah I don't see my mom or
my brother that often these people are
they know you better regularly I thought
that they know me personally I recurrent
you they made the current like a goings
on in your life but they're exposed to
me more often than other people so in
theory maybe it is a good thing and
maybe they do know if you're changing if
something's happening yeah and
with the kind of heart that's absolutely
something that's constructive you know
and I think about it too sometimes like
we sit here for an hour every week we
talk like unfiltered we stream live
which is completely unfiltered because
it's live
well I vlog four five times a week Jenna
makes you know it's like we're out there
we snapchat we're always there you guys
see us
you see our personality our day our our
life all the time so it's hard to
disputes you know some facts where it's
like I can't really say you guys don't
know what's going on my life yes to a
certain extent like I know there are
certain things I don't include on my you
know online life but that doesn't take
away the hours and hours and hours you
guys do get of me and you are able to
formulate are very accurate portrayal of
what goes on my life so yeah it's like
you guys keep up with us so so
up-to-date so recently that it's
sometimes it's hard to doubt that even
even if you didn't have the best in mind
for us that you wouldn't have a true
concept of what I'm going through right
but yeah in the case of marina we don't
know her home life or her home situation
maybe if you know she's posting
regularly on the internet that is her
you know those are the closest people
that see her the most regularly yeah you
know who knows and there was an
interesting comment under the video
before it was you know blowing up like
right at the cusp of like people being
very concerned and it said you know no
one knows what's going on in her life
and if it is some sort of mental illness
keeping her youtube channel regular and
uploading constantly could be at the
advice of someone like her therapist you
know maybe this is her escape maybe this
is what she does to feel regular normal
and have purpose and have a job and do
have something to do you know and
whoever's reading her that script is
just helping her you know do what makes
her happy and feel good furniture you
just never know what someone's life is
like there could be so many things going
on that we would never have thought of
well yeah
the possibilities are endless yeah right
it's just interesting to think like is
an audience entitled to tell people to
get help or to try and get people help
do they really know you do they not know
you do they
see you as regularly as they think or
you know what I mean it's just all
interesting it's very interesting
because then there's also the question
of are we being played like is there
whole online life and this is just like
super conspiracy people like every video
is over uploaded is this like oh yeah is
this one big long giant prank yeah
are we getting lonely girl 15 that's
what I'm saying that's totally a
possibility and that's something you
have to think about like especially in a
situation with like this where she
continues to act hmm I don't want to act
because you know might be inadvertent
but you know what I mean yeah but talk
like if we're going with the idea that
she's doing this for attention which is
again a possibility yeah that's crazy
yep are we get but like whenever
something like this happens on the
internet people [ __ ] take notice and
there's going to be copycat scenarios
900%
which is crazy it's wild scariest part
of that is like if in actuality this
girl's in pain right now and someone
sees it as as a she's doing it for other
reasons or B he's an attention this
could be another way to get you know
popular which is sick I think it would
it would make an amazing like scary
story or scary movie or scary whatever
oh yeah because the idea of her being
held hostage or something like this yes
she has debunked herself over and over
again that she's not being held hostage
that she's fine and her mom too has
spoken out about it right I don't know I
think I haven't haven't seen that but
maybe um but she's and we've ruled out
that as a scenario at least from her
that she's like imagine as well yeah
imagine like a short story or a short
film about a walker just making
everything being held hostage so it's
like people are commenting on my blog
like peach Park Julian's being held
hostage don't you know anything it's
turning into kind of like a joke and I
mean but it's absolutely riveting to
think about and you already know like
I'm willing to bet money sv is already
writing this thing
because you know anything Internet they
try to oh it's amazing yeah those are my
favorite episode yeah so good you're
like wow this is a direct ripoff of that
one story about X Y Z yeah way to go
Dick Wolf yeah or it's like the episode
with Logan Paul when they're your kids
visit their video get their like hackers
and their like streaming live from this
basement and it's like we are this this
is our demands and meanwhile they're
supposedly streaming from like a phone
and their audios like bang up and their
videos like very little you know
interference they're in a basement how
are they streaming live like this like
some of the best twitch streamers on on
the on the entire platform don't have
this good quality of money on video get
out Touche well I'm you know I want to
see what happened so I'm curious to see
how this pans out but um yeah I just
figured just this is a good discussion
to have I want to hear what you guys
have to say because you guys uh you guys
have seen it probably just as much if
not more than we have so um yeah let us
know in the comments like a general
consensus is that everyone I think hopes
that she's okay yeah you know obviously
yeah anyways anyways uh well what else
we're gonna talk about today the
Bachelorette okay boy boy um should we
go why are you looking at me like I'm
just ready to talk about that it's just
so irritating to me the whole thing is
irritating the show is irritating okay I
mean premises let me let me preface your
problem all right go ahead if you don't
mind okay
no keep the thought go ahead okay I
think I was so blown away last week when
Luke packed his bags but I was even more
blown away when he packed his bags and
his bag wasn't a five-star bag oh my god
yes so I want to give a quick shout-out
to our sponsor this week five star guys
some of the best school supplies some of
the most well-made materials that you
can buy if you're going back to school
your kids you have the cousins brother
you want to get them awesome
back-to-school stuff stuff five star is
what you need they have extra large
backpacks
last week with the expandable seven
inches additional for added space the
straps distribute weight perfectly so
your shoulders don't hurt and your your
stuff stays safe in your bag
chin is reading nothing there's no paper
and so I'm not reading it isn't it like
a tablet stand thing yeah
so cool yeah and so really this is so
cool
yeah you can stand it up you can sit you
can see on the inside there's clips for
your tablet you can like mount your
tablet instantly that also five star is
the brand of school supplies that is
with it in this time and age they have
stuff for your tablets they have stuff
for your notebooks your pens they have
awesome the zipper binder that we showed
you last week that is cool it's like a
combination of a binder and a folder
with zippers like man way really awesome
stuff so guys when you're going back to
school or you need things for
back-to-school choose five star for all
of your back-to-school needs
thank you five so also quick shout out
to mark box like we said last week was
last week and remember yeah peach has
fallen in love with the toy we got her a
bark box makes really really quality
toys and you can get yourself on a six
or twelve month membership plan and if
you use code Jenna Julian you will get a
month free on top of that so check out
and pick which size job yeah you
basically go online you go to bark box
calm and you check you check the boxes
what size dog you have what type of
stuff they'd like so they have a lab
they'll send you bigger towards your
service yeah and it comes more different
in a really nicely packaged box with
treats toys so your dog this is a toilet
paper toy like how cool is this
and it's peach like I'm telling you
peach Rex every toy we get her and she
hasn't even like busted it uh that's
more that's more at all like not even a
single thread has been compromised so
guys right now get a month free when you
sign up for six or 12 month subscription
plans with bark box at a bark bark box
calm slash annejulien and use promo code
Jenna Julian
lastly tracker guys this thing is so
cool
it's a out of you can see it they gave
us a special podcast trackers they are
very cool because the concept of putting
a tracking device on your item is great
in theory but so much goes into that
like you think about it and like I've
tried other ones and they haven't really
worked the battery dies this battery
lasts for one year so you put it in your
backpack you put in your laptop bag on
your keychain in your car so if you
forget what you parked in a parking lot
or whatever they you can put it in your
things and track it right to your phone
with GPS there's an app for it so easy
is to take the battery out it's like a
little thing not that you need to do it
though let's say once a year guys so I
literally just tell them I went into the
office and I just got my new camera
backpack so I'm like alright let's slip
on in here and I like tied it to the
inside and now I go on the tracker app
and I have the location and I can press
a button it's ridiculous make a noise if
it's around the house you people won on
the drone I super glued one to the drone
because I've had close calls with the
drone where I don't know where it landed
and then I'll find it with tracker or
even if someone were to take your drone
yeah and it's very inconspicuous like
this thing is literally the size of a
quarter it's crazy
there's silent mode if you prefer that
there's Wi-Fi safe zones which basically
means if it's in your house and you get
too far away from it it's not going to
alert you because it's your house so
right now guys get yourself a tracker go
to the th e tracker comm that's th e TR
a cker and use promo code Jenna Julian
for 30% of your whole order and start
tracking your things so you don't lose
them Matt Thank You tracker and you can
with that model like a pet collar what
am I your pet collar because I don't
like people microchip their pets
peachy's microchips right yes but that's
increment or not but that system is so
ancient you have to go that's like if
your dog gets lost and someone finds
them they bring them to the vet they
check their microchip but if you have a
little escape artist like last night we
just watch Carmen the nerve try and
wiggle through the front gate like if we
went outside and
you watch them they're like it was late
it was like 3:00 a.m. and it's quiet but
our gates shut and the gate has like
bars like about this wide
so you're like it's just on the edge of
like can they fit through it you know so
we just watched that no no no when we
moved in yeah you knew that karma and
marvels can get through them so we had
to chicken wire the back yeah but then
she can't but in the front yard there is
no chicken bar right yeah yeah so I
wanted to see a if Kermit would try more
marbles and be if karma could still fit
through it and this boy tried he tried
so hard like he had his head and his
shiny little worm body through there and
he kept jumping knocking together he's
like too big but so Kermit's a little
escapee and then Marvel just walked
right through it literally just walked a
fence right in front of us - but like a
microchip would help if your dog was a
little escape artist like that and got
out someone found them brought them to a
vet they microchip them and found them
but if you have a little escape artist
or maybe you're in a rural part of the
country where you like to walk your dog
off leash in the woods or some [ __ ] yeah
like you can put one of those on their
collar and then you can find them yep
you know yeah genius it'll literally
beep for you right yeah the seeps for
you is that if you're walking around in
the woods and you're like excuse me
Barry where are you bbbbbb babe there
you are yeah hey it's amazing it's wild
but also your car and somebody I'm sorry
no no thank you tracker this is a really
cool thing and we will absolutely use it
yeah Pete you're gonna get tracked he's
young yet tracks all right that's right
sorry so today guys is it if tonight
Monday night right the finale or is it a
week later
it's time hmm I don't know we should
look at all looking at you start your
piece nothing I'm just we talked about
this on Julien's vlog for a second
people have been asking for us to talk
about it but also if you don't want any
spoilers don't listen ahead because
we're gonna talk about its I didn't
spoil anything but there have been
spoilers out there that Jordan's brother
not Aaron Rodgers the other one was in
an interview and was talking about some
issues with Joe Joe present tense as if
they're still going on like all we're
working with
gonna like get this bubble ba some sort
of inside joke people are like you're
currently doing that
oh are you oh well that's up I guess we
don't have you never know what it is
today I just checked okay um so I've had
never watched The Bachelor of The
Bachelor before I was like that's trash
I don't really it's not interesting to
me at all yeah
not interested yeah and then last season
was the first time ever it's not that
I've ever watched an episode before I
feel like I had caught some episodes in
the past yes and I was like this is not
for me it's just not I can't do it but I
watched the season with Ben only because
I was watching something on TV and then
it came on yeah and then once I watch a
whole first episode I'm now I'm invested
yeah and now we have to watch it yeah so
I just was like you know what [ __ ] it
I'm gonna watch the [ __ ] bachelor not
one of those people yeah and I was
getting pissed because a so much of it
is fake and obviously fake and B I'm
pissed that I was watching The Bachelor
a piss I know I have moments like that
where like last season was the first
time I watched The Bachelor with then
and this season is the second time like
you and there are moments where I'm like
I [ __ ] hate myself so much that I'm
watching I'm watching I hate that I'm
watching as I hate myself for watching
this I hate you for making this I hate
everyone in the house for participating
is the fact that I'm mildly entertained
right now yeah you're like you resent
the fact that you're watching it and
there are the [ __ ] it and there are
certain people on the show that you like
you're like oh I feel you like I like
this person I can get where they're
coming from I see a personality and then
you're like they're on this show though
and they're like genuinely trying to
tell us that they're looking for love in
the most like [ __ ] ridiculous
scenario on earth and then it takes you
right out of it yeah like for me this
season on The Bachelorette there were a
couple guys that I was like okay he's
cool
okay he's cool but then at the end of
the day they're all just on the same
idiotic show doing the same idiotic [ __ ]
so it's like it's such a conflicting
feeling I don't know I'll watch it again
next season I know I will because now
I'm like on the train right well I think
it's interesting to think about just
within the history of reality television
it used to be sort of taboo to go on a
reality
show because they're like oh you're
gonna ruin your life yeah no one you
never gonna be able to get a job like I
remember back in the day with real world
and stuff people are like if you go on
that show you know you're ruining your
life much like if you had a youtube
channel no one's ever gonna hire you
Google search is ruining your life yeah
you're ruining your [ __ ] life why
would you ever do that and then I feel
like it became more like at least on MTV
like all those reality shows it's like
oh this is something for like the real
world they're the road rules or the
challenge like that oh this is just like
you know a cool thing for young people
to do to go live some life issues and
you know just live in front of a camera
but you're still a [ __ ] person and
then it became a viable career path for
people to do something with their lives
yeah you know you could get a career
from reality TV correct and that's the
point where we're at this point where
everyone knows that you know oh you're
not going to ruin your life by going on
a reality show yeah but you're doing it
because you want to get something out of
it at the end there's so many people
that go on reality shows with the best
of intentions that are just there to do
it which is all [ __ ] amazing and cool
like no one goes on Jeopardy to like
really get in with some director right
like there's nothing wrong with 90% of
reality television yeah cool do you get
your little home renovated do you man no
like no one gives a [ __ ] no but there
are so many people that if you like go
on these shows because they see it as a
viable career path which is irritating
to me and then you call that for - yeah
you know like we were watching the guys
tell all thing where the other guys were
in the reunion show or whatever and who
was Chad Chad I was thrown he ranks yeah
he was like he was like every one of you
guys are trying to get a career in
entertainment which is not wrong it's
like he's not wrong but you know if
you're if you're telling me that you
went on The Bachelor or about Troy and
you weren't like excited or even like
planning on the prospect of maybe having
a cool little following after you're
you're lying yourself otherwise you're
[ __ ] dating people in real life you
don't do that show if you don't care
about that so yes he's right yes all of
them probably would have benefit
from some some fame but dude you're on
the show too like nobody can say that
things on the shot period period I just
like it confuses me to no end why
someone would be like I understand that
I could get more attention and potential
work and like you know a semi career
after this yeah who wants that career is
that that's really the career that you
want but it's the same type of people
who start a YouTube channel to get
famous yeah it's like with the goal of
being famous it's a fictional career
path you know the people there's always
still people that do it genuinely as I
think there are contestants on The
Bachelor yeah that's right that are
genuinely there because they they want
to find love you know honestly and then
the rest of the people are there for the
wrong [ __ ] reasons or you know
somebody's there because they're
confused but like it just it there's
still genuine people but who are these
people
what's your life about this is the
career that you want really that's it
blows my mind blows my mind like I've
read a lot of theories that Jojo really
just wants to be in with Jordan Rogers
and he's cool with it too just so that
they know that they can have a little
bit more attention because of them yeah
it's like a it's like a symbiotic PR
relationship speaking of which who do
you thinks gonna do you thinks gonna win
tonight Jordan all right I told you I
think Robbie's gonna win no you don't I
do know you don't I wholeheartedly think
Robbie will win
now you don't yes I do no your job yes I
do no you don't the way they cut the
promo leading into tonight made me feel
like Jordan was acting a certain type of
way that was really uncomfortable told
you to win huh no that's not true I told
you guys I I also told you that I read
that she she tells him verbatim I wanted
it to be you and that he does something
with her parents or something like that
that upsets her too much I still think
that deals Mount of her stupid fake
[ __ ] cry I can't get over it well she
was coming I hate so much life episode
like stop
they said there was a moment when she
was clearing she saw when she sent Luke
home where she could like you could tell
she was like out of cry so she made
noises
yeah like when you do that but there's
no tears no tears no genuine like hurt
you can tell that you hear it in her
voice
yeah little tumors crying I asked you
the other day I was like I realized
after I asked you that you didn't you're
not a Bachelorette you know you don't
know things about that seasons are not a
true fan so like I was asking like do
the bachelorettes ambassadors Mountain
like cry this much normally is this
normal no it's just right now I know
that producers want them to cry look
we've been watching unreal which is
great [ __ ] I feels cool and I love it
and it gives you a lot of insight but
you have to remember it's a caricature
oh gosh oh it's like where's that nice
but like obviously whenever they cut
those like little sizzle reels together
for next week if someone's crying if
someone's like angry and screaming
obviously that was blood or way better
yeah so Jojo at some point every episode
is like got a new song infused
which is a terrible fake crier terrible
but like ours is this is our american
television culture though is remember
when we were watching hotel hell or like
even bar rescue sometimes and you can
tell in the later seasons they just are
like upping it like to be ridiculous
like bar rescue everything is a great
example because Barras use great show if
you don't haven't watched it that Jon
Taffer basically just goes to shitty
failing bars and then fixes their people
problem in there whatever please
incredible what he does he is longevity
and yeah and then read us their part so
the early episodes are legitimate like
you know someone's getting drunk on the
job or like they have a problem lots of
problems to fix them and then in the
later episodes it seems I keep one of
these cooked up dramas they send the
camera crew there a couple days before
Jon gets there and they must tell them
like the more desperate you're bar seems
the more likely that he'll come help you
so the employees are like fighting each
other outside like just crazy [ __ ] is
happening let would never really
actually happen yes yeah yes but I mean
it's it's a producer effect it's like
this you need yes are gone but so you
see that transition happen
within a series right yes and you get to
a point where you're like you know what
I would like so much more than this fake
[ __ ] is if you just did the show
straight up I like the concept you
already have me yeah I don't need all of
this [ __ ] I feel like honestly The
Bachelor The Bachelor I will probably
would have started watching a long time
ago if it was completely honest yeah but
you know the fear of becoming stale to
feel the fear of these shows becoming
irrelevant going off the air is so large
and then in that rat race to get number
one on Monday nights it's so big that
they're like who the [ __ ] cares what you
want we're going to make this the most
dramatic ridiculous [ __ ] ever oh it's so
ridiculous yeah but I feel you like some
of the most if someone best shows the
most like rewarding shows i watch or
just the [ __ ] straight up like yes
straight up if someone made like a
serious honest bachelor show and like
first of all by the first night they
could eliminate 90% of the contestants
it would have to be like a youtube
series three people you know maybe a web
series well I'm convinced that Jojo
probably already has her top three in
her head after the first [ __ ] night
Julie if you line up ten girls you know
or I line up ten guys I can tell you
after ten minutes which ones I would
probably like to get to know better
you know there's absolutely there's no
way that your red flags your your like
core indicators of a person don't go off
in the first [ __ ] 10 20 minutes of
meeting a person so you're telling me
that they spent weeks and weeks and
weeks together in the same house and now
she's making these tough decisions I get
it when it comes to two people but when
it comes to like six foot seven people
like no you knew that guy was a dick
you knew Chad was a joke like come on
like this is your fully knowing but like
well you said if they made a bare-bones
dating bachelorette show where it was
like no drama no one would [ __ ] watch
that period I know you would but no more
I would I would love it I would love
every second of it no group dates
no [ __ ] none of that garbage I
really just want to see someone just
have a real like genuine creating a
relationship that needs to be on YouTube
I'm telling you that's going to be like
a youtube series so like a version of
The Bachelor about Sarah where you know
I the only thing really draw
a stirring up is going to be a thumbnail
you know they're not gonna have to cut
together these promos they can just kind
of have but then again I Drive convinced
on well I think it would be cute because
as we're moving like people at the
height of reality TV everyone was like
this is amazing because it's not
scripted you know how refreshing is this
survivor and stuff and now we're at the
point where even television is too fake
for us so we go to the internet and
parts of the internet or to fix
everything is gonna be faking I think
they were craving realness and we find
that far more entertaining at this point
in our internet lives then the cooked up
[ __ ] goes right back to the marina
joist thing it's like that's why people
jump so fast at this event this thing is
real even if nothing happens they want
it it's it's it's intriguing you're
absolutely right there's so much fake
stuff being manufactured for
entertainment that is so the opposite of
entertaining sometimes I always see
something real it's like holy [ __ ] I
need this this is so that's what I'm
saying if there was a bachelor and it
was real or if there was other versions
of other reality shows on on YouTube or
on somewhere where you just cut out all
the [ __ ] and you just give me this
straight up what it is I find humanity
to be the most entertaining thing at
this point that's I mean a hundred
percent like take my page well being
real take a page out of why people watch
vloggers right yeah you watch people go
to the [ __ ] grocery store you watch
people sit down on their couch just i
watch your kid at all i watch your
grocery videos if you are one of those
people that uploads those videos i watch
them I genuinely watch people organize
their kitchen drawers yeah why because I
find it outrageously entertaining you
were on Twitch watching a guy blow glass
for two-and-a-half my mom was in town
she was there we were all on we were
commenting we were we followed this guy
sitting in a room flying blowing glass
like a [ __ ] monster
like putting these cream ade he made a
glass like a wine chalice with a [ __ ]
thing for his sight like a pipe holder
built into the side so he can smoke and
drink literally in the sink I was
watching somebody like domestic Dan or
something I think their name was I'm so
sorry if any of you are fans of these
people and we keep not saying their
names yeah you're gonna look them up I'm
gonna look up the guy we were watch
he gave like a Viking funeral Egypt ye
ji PT yes but we were watching um or I
was watching domestic Dan maybe I think
his name is and he gave a Viking funeral
to like a cookie that he burned or
something it was hysterical oh he the
guy in the kitchen right yeah he like
six different camera angles like music
play is so fantastic and he's not like
doing some big show I messaged him he
just said they're cooking and it was
like the most entertaining thing ever
his [ __ ] is cool I remember his dream
that kind of blew me away but like I
don't need you to create this fake
[ __ ] yaar [ __ ] I just want to
watch some goofy food in his kitchen
baking cookies or some guy blowing glass
what's so [ __ ] nuts is that this this
all comes full circle when you think
about the monster of reality TV or
Internet content that just is trying to
grab eyeballs any way they can this
circles back to them literally going
full circle from real - fake - fake -
fake - fake real yeah right like them if
you can imagine the marina joist thing
being a whole stunt right the people
behind that are trying so hard to get
people to watch that they're like let's
fake this real event let's make this
rich so real like it's it's almost the
bare bones of reality TV but it's gone
literally full circle it's jumped its
own she's jumped its own shark it's
trying to be fake real but it's fake
right what the [ __ ] I don't know but we
were talking the other day because we
watched my neighbor totoro for the first
time which was so embarrassing because
we'd been to Japan and I got the toys
like that's how the whole thing started
the first time I went to Japan was only
a layover at the airport because we're
on our way to Singapore and I got I
literally was in the airport shop store
whatever cuz we had like five hours it's
just me and ROM you weren't there yet
because you were graduating from college
that didn't Venice and Bali and I was
just standing in this store with Rome
and I saw the figure cat bus like the
little stuffed cat bus and I was like
crying laughing like cackling [ __ ]
laughing in this airport like a rude
person because I've never seen cat bus
and I thought it was the funniest thing
I'd ever seen him
so I bought a little cat bus and I
bought a little Kiki from Kiki's
Delivery Service which I still haven't
seen and I posted them on my Instagram
and was like I just got these at the
Japan
whatever Narita is and you're getting
married an airport and everyone's like
oh my god that's my neighbor totoro like
that's that's Kiki's Delivery Service
you have to watch the movies and I was
like wait these are movies I thought
that they were just you know toys so I
brought them back gave them to the dogs
and then a bunch of people sent us more
good DVDs yeah yeah like five of them we
had like five copy segments had them and
you guys know that I never watch any
movies yeah we had them in the living
room didn't watch this no they're blue
rink by the way pop in a blue ring kind
of blue red and then we went back to
Japan for a second time or the first
time really being there and I got like
seven cat buses like all these todos
like all this stuff still I've never
seen in the movies I just liked them
gave them as gifts and then we watched
My Neighbor Totoro
it was pretty special it was [ __ ]
incredible yeah and then like the night
after cuz we add you saw I've used all
my stash I was like almost in tears I
loved it too yeah and I couldn't believe
it had taken me that long to sit down
and watch it and yet every week I sit
down and watch this stupid [ __ ]
Bachelorette no no I'm like we watched
it the next night after we watch My
Neighbor Totoro
I know and we had this moment where we
looked at each other after our souls
like felt soulful from watching my
neighbor totoro and then we're like the
show makes me feel dead inside yeah it
feels like my soul is getting sucked out
every time I see Jojo fake cry about
some dude she knows she doesn't like oh
like it hurts my heart because it you
feel yourself getting more and more
shallow as you watch I'm wasting my time
all those hours I've got Bachelorette
but I could've watched something that
made my soul feel amazing I'm the
problem
you're not though I'm the problem okay
okay it turns that you're the problem
you're not are you
okay I'm part of the part now you're
sounding like Jojo but definitely by
comparison you watch a movie like my
neighbor totoro and you're like wow this
is this is really pure it's really sweet
it's really well done it's such a simple
story but it's also so like if you watch
it and you
think about it can be introspective if
you wanted to be you know it's just it's
very it's nice it's pure straight up and
you watch The Bachelor it's like nothing
about it is anything of that it's it's
all manufactured it's all fake it so
even if it is real it's all about
shallow [ __ ] anyway right so it's like
it's it's by comparison it does make you
feel like whywhy do I waste my time why
do I do especially you know not even
stuff that's like oh like it's a happy
fun movie like there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of documentaries
out there that I've seen so few of that
I would love to see all of yet somehow
I'm busy watching The Bachelorette on
him on Monday night I watch a fair
amount advice right oh yeah past and I
love documentaries and like I would like
to make one one day like documentaries
are the coolest thing to me because it's
like it's documenting some and I
wouldn't have to be serious it's just
real doesn't have to be serious but it's
it's like you take away so much like
when you watch a doc you take so much
away from it a doc yeah done why did I
just sound like really do she's got
certain eyes doc when you watch a
documentary you take you take there's
only something you take away from it
even if it was something that you don't
relate to at all like it could be about
something you never indicated yeah you
take something away not just like fake
cry my soul learns nothing from the
Bachelorette we were like dying laughing
at that conversation when she went to
whatever Utah Denver out [ __ ] out
with Chase and one of the contestants
and they had nothing like no conflict
that episode clearly so they just
started taught she was like so you're
your parents they're divorced right and
he was like yeah like what do you think
like is that gonna like affect your
ability to have a relationship like an a
future you think he's that yeah totally
like definitely and she's like okay I
mean you know we're we can talk about it
like we can work through it I'm like
this is a conversation that never
happens in real life ever we're gonna
work through the fact that your parents
got divorced and I think it might affect
our relationship but it's gonna take a
lot of time and communication like what
drunk conversation is this
half of the kids in this country's
parents are divorced right yeah do you
think anybody gives a [ __ ] yeah like you
talked about it maybe but just does it
affect your ability to [ __ ] hang out
with somebody no it's it's drunk trying
to make drama out of salvation don't
worry to reach to end all reaches but
there you go it's like that was a bad
week for the unreal side of The Bachelor
like they couldn't find anything they
can't make that immense communication
for us to like get over the fact that
your parents got divorced when you were
a kid like it's an active problem
between her and him garlic or even Lodi
or even like a relevant issue yeah
really
thing yeah maybe it affects him but why
why is it I think this is so bizarre
yeah I was so bizarre it was so ricci
and bizarre anyways I have to stop and
I'm still I would like to point out
again that at the end of the season of
The Bachelor when they announced Jojo as
the new bachelorette already said she
later I know but I'm saying of reminding
everyone she stepped over him there's so
symbolic like she didn't people this was
the person that you were on the floor in
the bathroom crying because he said that
he loved you yeah I broke your heart you
literally stepped over him to be the new
guy I can't look but that's that's
something I don't necessarily agree with
like you're saying that that her
stepping over him like he's a like
literally a name and object it shows
that her love for him was fake you just
got your heart broken by someone and you
had the chance to be the next person on
the big show of course you're gonna want
to throw the middle finger up to that
person like [ __ ] you you didn't pick me
here's my show only stop being a dick
she was in the friend zone I'm just
saying I'm just saying like it may be
symbolic if you think about it that way
but I think it's more bare-bones like
this person just broke your heart nuts
let's put your heart in their face can
but I'm just saying from a person who
believes that she actually liked him you
can identify with why she might have
want to stepped over him at the reunion
show to announce that she's now the [ __ ]
and he is not just playing devil's
advocate here fair enough fair enough
but you know what she I get I'm just I
think we should I think we should knit
Nick's Jojo talk for the rest I gotta
stop yeah
I'm aggravated and I need to reevaluate
what I do with my time because this
clearly isn't serving me this is hurting
me it's hurting my soul have this
discussion yeah I'm pissed all right
well we had to do it
[ __ ] thank you guys for hanging out this
week for another podcast and I'm sorry
I'm sorry
let us know in the comments what you
think about the Morita choice thing we
like to hear your thoughts and I'm also
really sorry about the Bachelorette
finale tonight or your predictions and
if we got it right or wrong or whatever
I think it's Robbie I'm gonna go play
with this toilet paper rollin out with
Pete please give it to weed - schism
filled it I'll give three efficient
program checkout bar Foxx go to barkbox
calm and use promo code Jenna Julian get
a month free with six or 12 month
subscription go to tracker comm use
promo code Jenna Dooley and 30% off and
use five star for all of your
back-to-school needs thank you to our
sponsors and thank you guys so much for
hanging out with us yeah fam I love you
every week I'm dad I gotta go
I've week that's better than Jenna's
attitude on the podcast
you